social media is really a narcissistic
place which is why it's so popular with
teams and Donald Trump so it's no
surprise the last week Facebook Twitter
Instagram are flooded with selfies
warped by the face app the software that
can make you look old or younger swap
your gender and you can even make you
smile look at what at kept simple did
with this image from the Great
Depression what uh whoa
or what a wonderfully respectful thing
to do history doesn't have to be so
depressing it wrote yes nothing to
present about a face scanning at the
twist reality so comedians I'm going to
show you a pic that has been face app
and for 250 points I want you to answer
a question about it first up although
president currently looks like a
jaundiced toe face up shows up an
alternate future where he is a young
stud Oh huh what's the name of hot
Trump's teen drama Marilyn Josie and the
grabbin by the Pussycats
kick her out you a minute Patriots coach
Bill Belichick here let's turn back into
a little boy tell us the fact of it I
can't tell which ones which uh tell us a
fact about baby Belichick Dave he's
actually a 36 year old lesbian named Jan
all right boys Carolyn he calls what he
doesn't in cipher the brown yeah next
one at Lindsey gold work tweeted what
the GOP would look like as women and but
I think our favorite selfie was maybe
lady Steve Bannon right there lady Steve
banning what's what's her political
platform Dave still a Nazi only this
time with sensible shoes all right boy
tax breaks for the wealthy and anyone
who can teach her how Facebook work ah
very good
knack Lady Liberty is giddy ye Isaac
Statue of Liberty so please alright
she's excited that Donald Trump is about
to deport her home to France ah good
Dave hill she's got like 80 guys in her
right now all right all right all right
lad if there's a government shutdown
she'll finally get a vacation yeah
vacation with 80 guys up in her yeah all
right kiddo
okay reducing that one more time they're
great yeah pump it out pump it out
Marilyn oh man and finally I I of course
tried to face up and now I know I'm a
hottest girl like I am
if you know you want some of that
oh you want some of that your Kristen
Bell I'm Kristen Bell now I know what
would look like when I get old too
there's old knee I'll still be hosting
30 show so comedians was it
I'm welcome to talking almost dead ah
what's the show old Hardwick old host
Mary Lynn singled out Dave talking Chris
not so Hardwick yeah boy
who's with me it happened all right at
4:00 p.m. deaf boy